our country needs to change the words of
the president of El Salvador speaking to
Sky News neighbor Kelly says the whole
nation has been shocked by the deaths of
migrant Oscar Martinez and his 23 month
old daughter valaria they drowned while
trying to cross the border from Mexico
to the United States mr. bacala has been
speaking to our US correspondent
Cordelia Lynch some Democrats in the
United States blamed Donald Trump for
their deaths
do you it's our fault he felt that
fleeing the country crossing three
borders a desert a river which they
finally drawn that for them they felt
that was safer than staying here they
traffic with kids to show their organs I
mean this is but but why would what
would people take those risks Donald
Trump said that a wall would have
stopped and ultimately saved Oscar and
Valerio what do you say to if they build
a wall migrants will build the tunnel or
they will go through the sea or they
will I don't know they they will go
through the to their sides of the wall I
mean a wall would not have stopped
anything probably a wall would cause
more deaths there were reports that
Donald Trump used an expletive to
describe your country shouldn't be
better if we build the country that's
not it and if someone wants to say it is
well he's wrong but right now I will
never call my home like that but but our
hospitals are crumbling our
infrastructure is crumbling our young
people or joining the gangs because they
don't have a job because they don't have
opportunities because their families are
being torn apart the immigration our our
countryside was very prosperous 50 60
years ago right now there are no jobs I
if you've seen the images released by
the American government today if the
detention centers where migrants from El
Salvador and other countries are being
held they showed overcrowding reports of
people not able to use the toilet while
managers said that it's a ticking time
bomb how concerned are you about your
people inside those detention centers we
have to come up with solutions first
because this can this can become a
humanitarian crisis it is a very
humanitarian crisis but it can become
something their worst
it's an incredibly divisive time in the
immigration debate and you have an
American president he's been accused of
being a racist do you think he is it's a
man you can do business with yeah he's a
businessman I mean you have to do
business and for us the United States is
just it's not a I mean it's not a thing
you can ignore I mean you're
economically dependent totally